on est sur un des ouvrages annexes donc
l'ouvrage 19 donc ça veut dire qu'il y
en a au moins une vingtaine pour aller à
versaill on arrête tout c'est le mot
d'ordre de la mobilisation organisée par
le collectif contre la ligne 18 et
l'artificialisation des terres ce
dimanche 14 janvier une grande marche
intitulée toxic tour entre Guill encour
et Châteaufort était mené sur le tracé
des futurs rails pour rappel ce métro
aérien devrait relier l'aéroport dorly à
la gare de versaill chantier des 2030
une aberration pour les membres
dénonçant le tronçon aér au milieu des
champs du plateau de saccl ça implique
une coupure une
fragmentation du
paysage une rupture des corridors
écologiques sur le plateau de saclé il y
a il y avait six corridors écologiques
avantarrivée de la ligne 18 il y en a C
qui sont supprimés il en reste un 6e qui
est très en danger et qui va rompre la
circulation de la faunne sauvage entre
les forêts de Rambouillet et la forêt de
versaill sachant que une ligne de métro
va appeler forcément euh l'aménagement
du territoire he c'est c'est la
politique officielle et que donc à long
terme vous allez avoir un territoire qui
sera très urbanisé et donc
potentiellement les Z nuis vont y passer
quoi le collectif dénonce la future
structure aérienne en béton armée du
métro elle impliquerait
l'artificialisation de 22 hactares de
terres agricoles où les nuisances
sonores dues au futur RAM pour les
habitations alentours malgré l'avancée
galoppante des travaux les militants
espèrent encore un retour en arrière
pour cette ligne 18
il y a eu quand même l'année dernière
plein d'éléments nouveaux il y a eu une
nouvelle étude sur l'impact sur la
biodiversité il y a les agriculteurs qui
qui continuent à protester sur le fait
que ça va les empêcher de de déployer
leur activité il y a des élus en
particulier dans les sones qui qui qui
ont dit que c'était pas possible de
continuer comme ça c'est la proposition
du collectif envisager un moratoire pour
se poser et regarder tous ces éléments
nouveaux qu'il a eu en 2023 cette marge
d'une trentaine de personnes ait dans le
cadre d'un grand weekend de
rassemblement assemblé atelier créatif
sur la biodiversité et spectacle était
aussi au programme du côté de manilé Ho
une mobilisation pour espérer voir ce
projet de plus de 20 ans
s'interrompre